you know it's funny because rayne he's
been on the podcast twice now hey and he
talked about he got he felt like at one
point he was sort of an [ __ ]
on the set and like where he was like
he's like i wasn't an [ __ ] i wasn't
mean to people i was just like in my
head and in a bad place and this and
that do you remember those times i don't
know what you're talking about i'm
scared
you do remember
because you know what you're talking
about he says people would know i'm sure
people would say i was mean but they
would say yeah i remember like you know
well yeah i mean he he was easy to make
fun of because he was a little bit of a
curmudgeon sometimes but but
i got to be honest with you i've been on
many sets like the comparison to
you know
some other major douchebags on sets is
you've worked with some douchebags well
yeah i mean let me tell you i i've been
or i've heard about you know i've i've
definitely heard horror stories i've not
worked with
mark you know
charlie sheen or anybody like that right
but you know
i've heard bad things about jim belushi
you know there's there's a few people
that have like a rep you know but you've
never really seen it on set where you're
like oh my god this guy is a diva or
this is no not not to no not too bad not
too bad yeah yeah and not that i can if
i say one thing about this you're going
to guess who it is and i can't say it
but
but it but it's not the office um but
yeah but you know it's it's a weird it's
not bernie mac
no i loved bernie was he great he was
the greatest i hear that he was the
greatest what do you remember about
working with him uh he was the most
generous he used to have this big lunch
in his room like you know you're
supposed to go to craft i mean to to
catering for lunch and he'd be like hey
come up in our in my dressing room he
has this huge dressing room all the kids
ate there with their moms he had like
different food up there he was like i'm
doing this he was so great he was so
grateful to be there he just made sure
everybody was super comfortable because
there were kids on the show we want to
make sure their parents were comfortable
are you kidding me it was awesome he was
awesome wow yeah it makes it even more
tragic knowing how great of a guy he is
you know and it's so funny the episode i
got to do for bernie mac creed is in
that episode creed bratton is in that
episode but he doesn't have any lines
he's like um
he's like a um like um
he's a background actor but he had he
was like a featured background actor
playing a doctor
so you kind of just see like the side of
his head or something was that funny
that we're both in the same episode but
i didn't know him then so i wasn't we
weren't in the same space so i i you
know i didn't get to meet him till to uh
the office but
remember when you would fart every time
you could on set yes and everyone loved
it yes yeah remember when you used to
wear sandals and shorts because they
were only shooting you from the waist up
because it was too warm remember when
you had big feet i i
yes talk though
what do you remember
listen anywhere you get your podcasts or
watch on youtube